the hierarchy of power in the DC
Universe is disputed at this point the
hierarchy of power in the DC Universe
is about to change if your perception of
Black Adam is based on the ad campaign
in Dwayne Johnson's hype machine you
think it was the greatest thing since
sliced bread but reality appears to be a
little bit more complicated while it's
far from a train wreck of a film Black
Adam is also far from the Paradigm
shifting film it was banned out to be
even with the inclusion of the Justice
Society of America Henry cavill's
Superman and Johnson finally portraying
DC Comics teth Adam after years of
waiting people didn't exactly rush to
the theater to check the movie out while
it claimed the top spot at the weekend
box office a few times in its run black
Adam's performance has been relatively
muted especially compared to the much
bigger run of black panther wakanda
forever Black Adam is resting just under
the 400 million dollar Mark in terms of
worldwide box office gross in isolation
that's an impressive number or a
superhero movie star in one of the
world's biggest movie stars it's a
little bit sus taken in context with the
movies reported 200 million dollar
budgets as well as a reported 100
million dollar marketing campaign the
amount of money Black Adam has brought
in starts seeming pretty small but is it
actually going to lose money that's a
point being hotly contested by industry
reporters the studio and the movie star
producer Dwayne Johnson himself that
debate has a new wrinkle now with a
bombshell report that Johnson's Camp
leaked misleading Financial info about
Black Adam on purpose to help spin the
movie's performance as positive and
profitable here's what the rumor mill
has churned up about the situation so
far his powers
are not a gift
but a curse on December 7th 2022
deadline explained that contrary to
other reports citing Black Adam as a
financial failure the movie stands to
rake in some profit after all the rough
window deadline reported puts the film's
projected earnings between 52 and 72
million dollars a number which allegedly
includes merchandise related to the film
less than a week later however former
editor of The Hollywood Reporter Matt
Maloney came forward with a surprising
claim that appeared to contradict those
numbers not only will Black Adam not
bring in millions for Warner Brothers
Discovery but according to baloney's
sources Dwayne Johnson's team purposely
leaked false financial information to
the Press on the industry newsletter
Puck bologna wrote amid all the reports
of Black Adam losing money team Dwayne
Johnson even took to leaking to deadline
and then tweeting a purported ultimate's
financial sheet bologna clarified that
no one on Johnson's team has yet
admitted to any such leak instead he
claims that individuals within Warner
Brothers Discovery have expressed their
belief that Johnson put those misleading
numbers out there leading to outlets
like deadline reporting on it and
propagating the a positive spin for the
movie if this report from Apollonia is
true it raises questions about the
ramifications for the movie's future in
the DC Universe as well as Dwayne
Johnson's relationship with Warner
Brothers Discovery before this rumor
came to light we learned that major
shake-ups are on the way for DC and the
Black Adam brand might have a lot to
worry about on December 7th 2022 The
Hollywood Reporter noted that under the
guidance of James Gunn and Peter saffron
the DC film and television slate to
supposedly up for some big changes
Wonder Woman 3 has been canned Jason
Momoa could switch from Aquaman to Lobo
and Henry Cavill may already be done as
Superman even though he just returned to
the role thr also reported that the
first black Adam's Financial woes could
take a sequel off the table entirely
regardless of what Johnson or the
movie's tantalizing post-credits scene
might have you believe so is the movie a
total failure that's up in the air but
if it was successful we probably
wouldn't have to ask for now the big
question is whether or not Black Adam is
really going to turn a profit or if it's
doomed to stay in the red I kneel my for
No One
[Music]